so last week I reported to you that
Donald Trump's personal lawyer I mean I
guess at this point we should say his
former personal lawyer Michael Cohen
lost his attorneys and was likely going
to be cooperating with investigators and
we've now learned according to friends
of Michael Cohen he is willing to talk
specifically about what he knows about
Donald Trump if given the right deal by
investigators and this is absolutely
massive because if there is a guy who
could take down Donald Trump it's likely
Michael Cohen at least from the
characters that we know about so far
there could be people we don't even know
anything about yet who have dirt on
Trump but from the people we know of
Cohen is one of those top guys and he
has been signaling to friends that first
of all he is going to be hiring a new
attorney reportedly after his attorneys
left him last week that new attorney is
guy Petrillo who's a very experienced
trial lawyer and not that we really
needed more information about that part
but it's very clear that Michael Cohen
thinks he's getting indicted and he
probably is getting indicted and guy
Petrillo is the type of guy you got you
hire if you think you're getting
indicted and that appears to be exactly
the direction that it's going but most
importantly Michael Cohen is the guy
whose loyalty to Trump was considered to
be unending and infinite and you might
remember when David Schwartz was one of
Michael Cohen's lawyers he went on Megyn
Kelly's program and said that the reason
why Michael Cohen is doing all this
stuff for Donald Trump the reason that
he fronted one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars for stormy Daniels by
mortgaging his own house it was because
of love for Trump and loyalty to Trump
but it seems like we're kind of getting
to the limits of that loyalty and love
and one of Cohen's New York friends
who's in touch with him said to CNN
quote he knows a lot of things about the
president and he's not averse to talking
in the right situation if they want
information on Trump he's willing to
give it and at this point who would
really expect that Michael Cohen would
maintain his loyalty to Donald Trump
Trump is basically abandoned the guy he
recently tried to put even more distance
between Cohen and himself by claiming he
hasn't even spoken to Michael Cohen for
a law
time here's a little bit of video of
krump saying that when asked about Cohen
late last week outside the White House
so your lawyer know is that my lawyer
but a lawyer but I always liked Michael
our yeah he's a good person not my
lawyer haven't spoken with them Michael
who hundred and thirty thousand what
stormy weather Oh stormy Daniels now
just doesn't ring a bell I don't know
what anybody's talking about I got a
tweet yesterday from a viewer saying I
shouldn't underestimate the possibility
that the entire internment of child
migrants was to take attention away from
what's happening with the Trump Russia
investigation I'm not so sure I'm not so
sure but speaking about that
investigation does anybody remember how
the steel dossier said that a man named
Michael Cohen went to Prague for some
sketchy meetings with Russians and when
we heard about that Pat the response
from Cohen was I've never been to Prague
check out my passport there's no stamp
from Prague from the Czech Republic he
never walked the land of Prague so maybe
he just went to the airport right I
started thinking about this more and I
don't know why I didn't realize this at
the time I don't know how this eluded me
for so long but yesterday when I was
reading about this story and reading
about that assertion in the steel
dossier and the prog stuff Prague is the
capital of the Czech Republic the Czech
Republic is part of what's called the
Schengen area okay the Schengen area is
a group as Pat well knows based on his
recent European adventure the Schengen
area is a group of 26 European countries
that have gotten rid of all passport and
border controls and what this means is
that if you enter the Czech Republic
from another Schengen country you don't
even show your passport
never mind getting a stamp on your
passport and I experienced this when I
was last summer traveling from Belgium
to the Netherlands and back to Belgium
and into
no passport at any time and Michael
Cohen could have avoided the infamous
stamp on his passport by first going to
any other country in the Schengen area
before going to Prague and he wouldn't
have a passport stamped so at this point
don't we have to think that there is a
very good chance that it's not some
other Michael Cohen we heard that was
one defense from the trumpet that's a
different Michael Cohen it's not this
it's a different Michael Cohen who of
course we have no idea who that other
Michael Cohen would be isn't it more
than likely that he did go to the Czech
Republic but entered from a different
country yeah I'm just gonna steer this
in a little bit of a different direction
for a second I brought up the child
detention centers yeah Michael Cohen
said about that that son of a Polish
Holocaust victim someone who has escaped
the Nazis presumably he was very upset
with this and chaough children should
not be used as bargaining chips so if
he's willing to flip on the Trump
administration in public would he be
willing to do so behind closed doors in
front of the Muller team I would say
yeah I think there's a chance by the way
one quick note so yes it'd be Michael
Cohen expressed opposition to the
internment of little kids in cages and
as a result he also resigned as a
Republican National Committee finance
chair how insane is it that he was still
a rat of Republican National Committee
finance chair up until just a couple of
days ago that is truly stunning and a
lot of people didn't know that that he
was still actively a finance it's not
the finance chair it is a finance chair
for the Republican National Committee
hopefully the truth will come out
eventually I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show send me your thoughts what can we
expect from Cohen